Imagine your body without a skeleton.
You would be a helpless, floppy pile of tissues.
Your skeleton gives you support and allows you to move.
Cells also have similar needs,
and they too,
have a skeleton--
a cytoskeleton. A cytoskeleton,
which is made of protein filaments,
is found in virtually all life.
The cytoskeleton filaments form by a process called polymerization.
Polymerization is similar to stringing small beads end to end to make a necklace.
In the case of the cytoskeleton,
the beads are individual proteins,
which associate end to end.
However,
unlike a necklace,
which is always the same length,
cytoskeletal filaments are dynamic.
They grow and shrink by adding or losing proteins.
This allows the cell to rebuild its cytoskeleton, positioning filaments when and where it needs it.
Two types of cytoskeletal proteins are actin and tubulin.
Actin polymerizes in a twisted pattern to make actin filaments. Tubulin
polymerizes into microtubules,
which are shaped like cylinders.
In addition to providing the cell with structure,
actin filaments and microtubules also act as roadways.
Motor proteins walk along these roads,
carrying cargo to different parts of the cell and producing forces.
For example,
myosin is a motor protein that moves along actin and is the major force behind muscle contraction.
In fact,
when you eat a steak,
the main proteins that you're eating are actin and mysoin.
But what else does the cytoskeleton do? Microtubules grow and shrink to move
DNA into two new cells when cells divide. Actin filaments grow and
shrink to push cells forward as they crawl,
allowing cells, like white blood cells, to move through your body and fight invaders.
And what about all the different beautiful shapes of cells in your body?
These are made possible by the underlying support structure,
the cytoskeleton.